the Dodgers the LA Dodgers who invited
this satanic drag troop the sisters of
Perpetual Indulgence who mock not only
Catholic nuns but mock Christ and the
crucifixion and are just not doing good
stuff uh invited them to be honored for
pride month at Dodger Stadium and then
there was backlash so they disinvited
them then there was backlash to the
backlash so they reinvited them and now
they're going to hold
a Christian Faith and Family Day in July
I think they already were hosting that
but they're promoting this now okay
not good enough even Bishop Barron who's
a very nice is Catholic bishop very nice
guy he's not really a bomb thrower or
anything he points out he says this is
just not enough uh
you know we cannot accept the LA Dodgers
for doing this we've got to keep the
pressure up
we should boycott the LA Dodgers we
should protest the LA Dodgers we should
put the LA Dodgers on the transheiser
bush Target Cole's list this is
completely unacceptable stuff
and I know that there are going to be
people speaking of that old style
Republican politics sort of thing uh who
are going to be people who say well look
can't we just meet in the middle
somewhere or can't we don't we can't
boycott every company can't we just all
right they're going to have the look
they're gonna have the satanic parody of
the mass uh devil worshiping drag queens
day but they're also going to have a day
where they
acknowledge the existence of Christians
so look isn't that kind of a win no no
you can't please at everybody that's
always the case but you especially can't
please everybody during periods of
intense division
so when we broadly agree on things it's
easier to please more people more of the
time when we can't agree on anything
when we can't agree on what a woman is
when we can't agree on anthropology when
we can't agree on epistemology only
candy Gran what good and bad is when we
can't agree on what the role of the
state in good and bad is when we can't
agree on language the meaning of
language then you really can't please
everybody all of the time that then your
your to be politically successful
you're probably only going to please a
minority of people when you live in
Revolutionary times which the left has
voiced Upon Us time and time again but
but especially now when you live in
Revolutionary times then the way you're
going to make political change is is to
appeal to a minority of people
at all times it is it is a minority of
people who make revolutionary change
think of the Bolsheviks who who
dishonestly presented themselves as the
majority they were a distinct minority
of people
look at what's going on the baseball
audience is broadly conservative the
people who run baseball are
extraordinarily left-wing and they're
they're cow Towing to left Wingers well
look what happened Anthony Bass the
Toronto Blue Jay he comes out he
criticizes pride month then there's
backlash from his bosses presumably so
he throws his integrity under the bus he
makes an apology for attacking pride
month and then he trots out there onto
the field listen to how the Blue Jays
fans greeted him
look at this
you can hear one boo in particular
and then
he trots out there
has a little conversation in Shallow
left field
okay
still it's sometimes a little hard to
make out what the audience is saying
here
[Music]
but then it becomes a little clearer
is he's trotting from shallow left field
out to the pitcher's mound you hear the
booze
why was he booed
he was booed because now nobody supports
him people are raving about genucel skin
care Jessica from Huntsville Alabama
says my skin looks so soft and clear
I've seen a reduced number of fine lines
and dark spots I found a new lifetime
product absolutely love it Jen you sell
skin care uses a one of a kind
proprietary flower base developed by the
founder and pharmacist who is a great
guy by the way it's also comes along
with rare Botanical extracts and
Powerful antioxidants for skin care
results that work guaranteed I said I
would not endorse the product if I could
not try it if I were not impressed by
the product and also fellas I know
sometimes men are a little skeptical of
getting into Cosmetics too much even
slightly more men than women use
genuscal and for good reason geniusell's
most popular package is available to you
today for seventy percent off 7-0 at
genucel.com knowlesyt join millions of
happy customers who've already fallen in
love with the results Plus for a limited
time get geniuses probiotic extract
moisturizer free with every most popular
package go to genucel.com
knowlesytgenucell.com knowlesyt
the pro
Pride people obviously don't support him
he he posted to his Instagram a very
clear directed video about how he thinks
pride is evil
the conservatives don't like it the
normal people don't like him because he
then threw his integrity under the bus
said oh I'm sorry I offended I never
wanted to offend anybody you know I'm
sorry the pride Community I support them
blah blah blah okay so now he's got
nobody I'm reminded in Dante's Divine
Comedy
right right at the very beginning of
hell are the people who were lukewarm
and they're there it's not the deepest
part of hell it's not the hottest part
of hell it's it's in some ways though
even
more ignominious because it's it's the
people who are obviously unacceptable to
Heaven because they have no conviction
they have no Integrity then they have no
faith but they're also repulsive to the
people in hell
even hell won't accept these people
they're just to be spit out they're just
so lukewarm
don't do that there is nothing ever to
be gained by apologizing to an unjust
mob there's one time I was on Fox News
and I uh
I was I was asked about environmentalism
on the left and I said it was unjust
that the libs are exploiting a mentally
ill Swedish child to promote their
totally incoherent agenda and the host
of that program Harris Wagner didn't she
didn't bat an eyelash this is obviously
a true statement the Democrat who was on
the panel uh Chris Hahn he made a big
deal about this and yelled and screamed
but still the viewers weren't upset it
was obviously true that you know when it
came to the case of this gal Greta
thundberg her mother actually wrote a
book about how this girl had all these
sorts of mental problems and yet she was
still being exploited as the face of the
left so that we couldn't criticize their
climate policies so I just said this on
air and then some of the liberal
Executives at Fox made a big deal about
this and yelled and screamed and all the
rest of it and there was a big push
there were some emissaries from Fox News
who implored me to apologize to the
company publicly
and they said oh you'd be back you'll be
back on air in two seconds if you just
apologize and I said well I don't think
I did anything wrong if I felt I did
something wrong I'd consider apologizing
but I don't think I did I think that and
that was one of the early cases where
the conservative audience
had a backlash against Fox News for
something it did that they felt was
liberal and dishonest I said I'm not
going to do that
now maybe it would have gotten me on Fox
News probably it wouldn't happen I mean
look at what just happened to Tucker
Carlson and I also went back on Fox News
relatively quickly after that anyway so
it wasn't
the devil always does this to you the
devil always gives you these sort of
Temptations and says hey if you just
throw away your integrity hey if you
just throw away your beliefs if you just
throw away your faith I'll reward you
seriously pinky swear promise and then
what happens when you make that kind of
a fasting bargain you get nothing
Anthony bass learned that the rest of
the normal people should learn that too
boy what a great clip that was make sure
you subscribe ring that Bell Michael
Knowles YouTube channel we'll see you
next time